[Música]
de la mano de cuantos millenials y
centenas hay en la sala nacidos entre el
90 y el 84 84 y 2000 respectivamente soy
en que para 2030 vamos a hacer más del
65 por ciento de la fuerza laboral
activa sin embargo si buscamos
bibliografía sobre cómo nos comportamos
en el sector laboral encontramos que los
millennials son siempre acusados de que
se les complica mantener un puesto de
empleo de que prioriza la vida personal
sobre la vida laboral de que no tiene
compromiso y no puede estar mucho tiempo
prestando atención y se le atribuye la
causa al exceso de información que
tenemos gracias a la información digital
y a los medios de información que usamos
frecuentemente sin embargo el problema
es otro y es que el management
tradicional está enfocado en las viejas
empresas y las compañías ya no son lo
que eran posiblemente vean esto y se les
sea familiar con un periodo anterior de
cómo se publicaban y de cómo se hacían
los anuncios y obtienen esta forma tal
como mercado libre o lx amazon a nivel
internacional los taxis han sido
reemplazados por los uber las
experiencias con los distintos medios de
comunicación
que era radio televisión revista hoy
tienen esta forma y posiblemente los
actores que eran protagonistas de los
anteriores medios de comunicación no
sean los mismos tenemos influencias en
youtube en instagram mucho ustedes
seguramente se informan por twitter y no
leen el diario y estás como así como
mencionaron muchas otras como la de los
cines o netflix estas son las empresas
que nosotros vamos a terminar liderando
y siendo tomadores de decisiones y
siendo gerentes y si os
entonces la consulta es tenemos
competencias suficientes para hacerlo
tenemos la información suficiente para
hacer líderes de compañías como estas y
poder llevarlas a cabo de una forma
exitosa yo los invito a reflexionar
sobre tres puntos principales que creo
que son los más relevantes y que cuando
se estudia como emiliano de docente a
los jóvenes vamos a poder formar el
sector laboral están omitiendo el
primero de ellos es la competitividad
hoy ya no competimos contra una persona
que estudia con nosotros en la misma
aula o un graduado la misma carrera en
otra universidad o en un país vecino hoy
competimos contra el mundo gracias a
linkedin tenemos acceso a millones de
currículums libres y gratis donde un
empleador puede hacer un solo clic
contactarlo enviarle un contrato
electrónico firmarlo asignar un trabajo
y diferir le en los honorarios por
western union o por cualquier medio de
pago electrónico y tener una prestación
de un servicio sin incurrir en los
gastos de oficina de capacitación de
cargas sociales de logística que te
implica tener una persona física
oficinas entonces saca las preguntas son
dos en principio si la modalidad de
trabajo que hasta ahora venimos
desarrollando que es nueve horas en una
oficina haciendo un trabajo donde está
testeado que solamente se trabajan entre
dos y tres horas diarias ese es el
esquema de negocio y es ese a la
información que nosotros estamos
teniendo hoy día suficiente y
competitiva para el mundo laboral les
voy a citar un ejemplo personal mi
abuelo se recibió acá en esta casa en el
año 1962 fue de la primera camada de
ingenieros graduados él se recibió de
ingeniero mecánico y ejerció toda su
vida hasta sus 50 años que interrumpió
por un problema cardíaco y fue gerente
de una empresa metalúrgica muy
importante su título universitario bastó
para su éxito laboral
yo me recibí acá mismo en el año 2014
pero si una ingeniera inmediatamente
después y su máster y es a día de la
fecha y lo anunciaron antes de cuando me
presentaron que seguí estudiando y mi
hermano que está acá presente estaba un
final de recibirse de ingeniero
industrial también en la casa y ya hace
un año le están pidiendo desde el
trabajo que haga un curso de project
manager porque no es suficiente la
información que recibimos en la academia
y no hablo del ateneo porque estoy
convencida que en ingeniería
si no si es suficiente los planes de
estudio como están estructurados vamos a
un segundo problema que tenemos con
cuestión que tenemos que presentar los
jóvenes a la hora de ser directores de
empresas importantes que es cambio
climático muchos de ellos serán
conscientes que estamos incurriendo en
un calentamiento global y que la razón
de la frecuente y constante y permanente
contaminación tenemos que fijar un
objetivo de reducción de gases de efecto
invernadero para no seguir afectando el
entorno que nos rodea y ese proyecto es
a 2050 ser cero neto de emisiones que
implicaría emitir gases de efecto
invernadero en proporciones iguales a lo
que el mundo es capaz de absorber es
decir tenemos que pensar muchísimo en
todas las acciones y las empresas no van
a hacer solamente rentables desde el
punto de vista económico sino que
también van a tener una componente
ambiental y ese componente ambiental
tiene que estar ponderado voy a citar un
caso por el absurdo pero para que me
entiendan por a dónde voy
argentina no sé si sabían tiene unas
reservas de litio más grandes del mundo
lo que salta y jujuy donde están los
alares obtenerlos es como un proceso
minero una vez que se obtiene el litio
se lleva en camiones hasta el puerto de
buenos aires le dice sube un barco se
lleva a esta china en china se
manufactura ahí se hace la batería todo
el packaging asociado al producto final
que es plástico que sabemos que nos
biodegradable de ahí se vuelve a montar
en un camión hasta el puerto un barco y
llega a la argentina en forma de batería
comercial que la podemos utilizar para
autos eléctricos que son amigables con
el medio ambiente o bien para proyectos
de energía por ejemplo solar
fotovoltaica entonces la consulta es si
a esa toda esa transición le ponemos un
costo económico y en la huella de
carbono que implica todo ese proceso y
esa logística asociada se le asigna un
valor económico sigan siendo los mismos
actores del mercado sigue siendo el
comercio internacional conveniente o no
conveniente con el esquema de modelos
actual actualmente tenemos un precio que
lo fija el mercado que su oferta y
demanda un costo que es la sumatoria de
transacciones costos vinculaciones
directas
y una utilidad y si queremos ser más
productivos directamente buscamos un
nuevo marca donde los precios sean más
altos o reducimos los costos haciendo
más eficiente los procesos pero qué pasa
si yo hay sal y sumó la componente
ambiental eso lo vamos a tener que
pensar nosotros y las empresas del
futuro va a tener que tenerlos en cuenta
como un tercer aspecto que para mí son
más relevantes y que presenta dos caras
de la misma moneda la esperanza de vida
en los últimos 30 años aumentó hasta un
27 por ciento esto quiere decir que la
gente vive casi un 30% más
obviamente que depende de la riqueza del
país países más ricos tienen mejor
acceso a la salud países más pobres
lamentablemente no esto es un promedio
pero la gente vive más años y hoy es un
tema que se está tratando sobre todo
brasil por ejemplo es actualmente
revolución de bolsonaro como van a
tratar los sistemas de jubilación porque
no alcanzan los años de vida activa del
profesional para repagar los años de
jubilación y de pensiones entonces eso
es muy fácil se resuelve extendiendo la
edad ya no te jubilas a los 65 a los 70
sino a los 75
pero quiere decir que tenemos cada vez
más personas activas y a todo esto
sumamos que las mujeres estamos cada vez
más activas en el sector profesional
también pues tienes muchísima más gente
que emplear y como contraparte estamos
viviendo un proceso de automatización
que quiere decir la automatización ya
todos los trabajos que sean manuales son
sustituidos por una máquina cualquier
movimiento que haga nuestras manos es
muy fácil generar una máquina que las
reproduzca y las haga todavía más rápido
y mejor con mejor precisión y ahora bien
es un estudio de mckinsey todas las
profesiones el 60% las profesiones
convencionales que conocemos tienen
hasta un 30 por ciento de automatización
y con eso me refiero carreras simples y
convencionales por ejemplo la medicina
todo lo que sea pre diagnóstico porque
un estudio de sangre estudio de orina y
una resonancia magnética se puede hacer
por inteligencia artificial un
diagnóstico preventivo una probabilidad
de ocurrencia futura y de esa forma
evitar muchísimas investigaciones la
parte de los abogados toda la parte
burocrática que es papelería que se
puede digitalizar y resolver muy
fácilmente
contadores con unas excelentes muy
buenos macros que les resuelven
componentes mi hermana que estudia
arquitectura cuanto le facilitaría en
hacer cargas mecánicas si directamente
tiene un software y la parte de
innovación y de diseño obviamente que es
humano y es estético pero toda la parte
de análisis estructural que es
resistencia de los materiales se podría
perfectamente automatizar con vigilancia
cuántas ciudades vemos tres policías y
sin embargo está todo monitoreado por
cámaras inclusive lo que son los pilotos
ya hay muchísimos autos en japón que se
manejan son los que tienen arriba un
sensor de movimiento y que reemplazan la
función del chofer es decir la tendencia
se vuelca la automatización y cada vez
son menos prescindibles los puestos de
trabajo convencional
entonces la consulta es que no garantiza
que el recibirnos y el salir con una
carrera universitaria nos genera un
empleo y cómo vamos a hacer a futuro
para que toda la masa de profesionales
que va a desenvolver el mercado
educativo tenga efectivamente un rol
laboral para desempeñar
si están acá es porque les gusta las
charlas de verdad la charla te da más
vista de todos los tiempos es de que
robinson él es un inglés que establece
que el sistema educativo corrompe la
innovación pero es se basa
exclusivamente en los componentes de
cognitivos en el metodología de
aprendizaje de la primaria y de la
secundaria y de cómo los niños
incorporan nuevos conocimientos yo hago
y coincido prueba una contrapartida los
contenidos que estamos viendo son
efectivamente los más útiles para
desempeñar a futuro una buena ejecución
de labores y son realmente útiles a las
necesidades laborales del mercado
yo quiero si tal es un ejemplo muy
simple también para incluir a mi tercera
hermana y nombre a de los tres por igual
que tengo la hermana de diez años leyó
efectivamente 18 años
la chiquita es una escuela bilingüe de
la capital federal la zona de caballito
llegó un diccionario español español así
debe tener unas 650 páginas y de pesar
cerca de unos dos kilos español español
dije vienes
e ideas en dejar el celular en la puerta
es claro que muchos componentes del
teléfono celular se vuelvan a usar
whatsapp o manda hace fotos con carita
de perrito por snap tag y demás pero
cómo vas a inhabilitar a los chicos de
la herramienta más útil que tienen de
trabajo en posibilitar que aprendan a
utilizar como una herramienta
poderosísima para acceso a la
información para contactarse para tener
justamente metodologías de análisis
muchísimo más eficientes que la mera
presencia recordemos que tenemos
estudiantes del siglo 21 con docentes
del siglo 20 y con metodologías de
aprendizaje y temáticas de estudio del
siglo 19 nos empezaron alguna vez cada
cuánto cambia un plan de estudio o cada
cuanto nace una nueva carrera y en mi
criterio ese es el desafío que nosotros
tendríamos que proponer que cambian para
que se nos sea más eficiente la carrera
como líderes o como gestores o como
sitios de empresas digitales
con esto quiero ir resumiendo
efectivamente tenemos una gran
oportunidad los jóvenes de llevar
adelante un cambio tenemos que invitar a
toda la comunidad laboral a repensar los
planes de estudio a ver si efectivamente
podemos conseguir carreras
universitarias que nos garanticen la
inserción laboral y sobre todo preparar
a los jóvenes en carreras que nos sean
más útiles para los requerimientos
futuros estamos en un momento de cambio
y depende de nosotros llevarlo a cabo
con éxito o seguir como estamos y morir
en el intento muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]